I got laser eye surgery a month ago oh
yeah so you got the laser yes great I
can see everything was the surgery
painful they numb both of your eyes
using numbing drops and then they come
over the top with a kind of a large box
on an arm they rest the valve of the
front of this box on the eyeball itself
and then suck the eyeball onto the
actual valve so that it can't move they
then use one laser to create a flap in
the cornea you're still lying back you
have to keep looking at a green light
that's above you the surgeon will lift
the front flap of the cornea up using
kind of a soft pair of tweezers the
laser will then come in behind now the
opened part of the cornea do the
corrective surgery the flap will then
get replaced had it done on both eyes
one day of recovery it feels very gritty
was it an expensive procedure 5 grand
USD after this corrective surgery 2015
Vision everything's razor sharp and I'm
very very impressed and thank you to my
surgeon for doing it